hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well so this is
another example video where I'm trying
to provide some applications and
examples for Jeremy Bentham's
understanding of utilitarianism as more
theory were touring around greatest
happiness principle which says that the
right action for a person to pursue the
right choices for them to make are those
which maximize happiness and pleasure
minimize pain or displeasure unhappiness
misery not just for themselves but for
all who are concerned in the situation
so this requires us to do some balancing
at times of some people's pleasure
against other people's pain and Bentham
thinks that you can actually quantify
all the sort of stuff rigorously
I'm not actually gonna try this this
case to provide sort of quantifiable
tables and arguments about each of these
instead I'm going to propose these as
things that if you want to think about
in a utilitarian way and try to walk you
through how you point how you might set
that up
because some of these are dependent on
factors so this one is about
romance sex dating all these sorts of
things is a very important part of our
our lives one in which I think that just
culturally we're not on the same page as
Jeremy Bentham who's you know in many
respects a creature of his own age and
we're living after the various sexual
revolutions and the proliferation of all
sorts of issues and you know this is an
important part of our lives for many
people that spell to be an irreplaceable
part of their their lives and not just
the sex part but also romance you know
finding a relationship flirting all
these sorts of things so there's there's
many many many topics that we discussed
when it comes to this but I'm just going
to talk about a few see if we can
actually get through this whole list and
look at them in a utilitarian
perspective so we don't look at how
these sorts of things the decisions that
people make affect everybody concerned
in terms of pleasures and pains so let's
think about dating and hooking up in
Chapel all right and you could say
dating versus hooking up hooking up
means you run into somebody and you know
places you or you work with them or
there at the bar or something like that
you go home
you you have sex with them maybe their
home or don't you somewhere and it's
just for fun it's just there's there's
no actual commitment there whereas
dating you actually want to try to get
to know the person for who they are I
mean ideally these we could actually
talk about the ethics updating you know
what should you be doing but if we want
contrast these let's contrast up as
rigorously as possible so so hooking up
this meet up with somebody
both you fighting to attractive go back
to rather have sex sex is enjoyable it's
fun to do that sort of thing that that's
producing pleasure happiness for the
people involved dating is a longer-term
process you know it's evolving to know
the person drink some activities
together which might later on down the
line lead to having sex but are not
necessarily geared towards that you
could date without actually want to have
sex you know make you want to wait until
you're married or something like that
now let's think about there's immediate
pleasure coming with hooking up right
and presumably there's an officer to
coercive situation and you know we have
and those are things then we got to
adjust the balances in this case isn't
really the best thing to do though or as
dating them you know you could think
about the different ranges of pleasures
so you know sexual pleasure is is pretty
intense but it doesn't last
and if you want to have more but you've
got to keep doing right and nope you
know it's not just that the pleasure of
having sex that somebody has you know
they come to work the next day and they
say oh you're very good mood you know
you're like so maybe maybe there's
something else that goes along with that
having to do with you know that's a well
being or succeeding or something like
that people enjoy it right so that's
that's pleasure any canes that might
come with that well you know your tears
that have silly example think about the
proverbial walk of shame nothing to do
social disapproval right you might say
well who cares about one of the people
well people actually do care about what
other people think and if you're if
you're utilitarian you care about what
other people think if it if it bruises
pain or pleasure right so if soul
disapproval is one of the consequences
that sometimes comes with hooking up
verses dating you know from utilitarian
perspective that that lowers the balance
of pleasure and pain you know you could
also say if it's a hook-up situation and
one person thinks that there's gonna be
a lot more their real relationships
evolving and the other person says no
I'm just here for the sex now the
southern person there could be pain
attendant upon that Bentham would say
that means likely to resolve for them
and even if there is just a possibility
that it's going to result from it he we
have to take that into account not as
highly as you know absolutely certain
you know sure thing but you would take
that into account
whereas yeah I mean dating okay of
course you know there's things that go
wrong on days too so you might want to
take those
probabilities into account but you do
get to know the curse there are some
goods that can come out of dating that
might not come directly out of cooking
up or ever an amino social approval or
disapproval to be part of that how other
people see you that can be part of that
because that produces pleasures and
pains so let's leave that one sit let's
let's move on to question promiscuity to
be common right should you sleep with
just about anyone should you or should
you be pinky who you have sex well you
know you can think of a lot of different
ways that you can get yourself in
trouble by being fairly indiscriminate
with who you enjoy sexual pleasure you
can find yourself with somebody who's
abusive which you know is probably for
them some unpleasant but for you is
going to be painful and so you know the
overall balance of the situation that's
probably not as good of a things but
somebody who's not right can lead to a
bad reputation for various reasons there
could actually lead to a good reputation
depending on the culture that you're in
as well possibility of contracting
various diseases of getting yourself a
tangled and romantic relationships that
you didn't mean to hurting other people
in the process you know arousing
jealousy all these sorts of things come
with that putting yourself in a
situation where your reputation that
leads other people to only see you as a
sexual object again from utilitarian
perspective you would want to look at
how
everybody is affected by this if it's
just you and you're on your own then you
would look at how you are affected by it
is a good thing for you or abandon for
you is the trade-off of getting sexual
pleasure whenever you want to go to
whatever you're able to access it it
does that operate the disadvantages and
pains that that can come with that as
well mostly psychological things but
could be physical things well if you
have other people involved in the
process if you're not just great
learning partners you know if your
partner's don't know that you're
promiscuous then you might have the
problem right it could cause pain for
them let's say everybody is in and out
like it's a bunch of swingers or
something right now if you actually have
other people in some way dependent on
you or who are affected by your condoms
their pleasures of teens are important
to let's say you have kids let's say
you're a single parent can you go out
and sleep with whoever you want it's not
quite the same as being on your own now
is it now you know kids they can be
greatly affected by that can produce a
lot of pain for them if they not fear
actually doing a lot of well years ago
so much don't use my new boyfriend she's
my new girlfriend that produces
instability that bothers kids they don't
usually see that as you're also taking
time away from perhaps all the things
you should be attending to so you know
these are the things you have to take
into account so from a utilitarian
perspective of course if you could like
arrange things in such a way that it was
just all pleasure nobody
is getting any pain come on it's then
you know like an in brave new world
you know Huxley's story that would make
sense wouldn't it but usually that's not
the situation we find ourselves in and
utilitarianism doesn't just say well we
should change the world so it can all be
they get a playground
it actually looks at the world that
we're in and says look in the situation
that you're in if you're going to hurt a
bunch of people by your the continent
don't do it
pornography that's an interesting one
too this is a huge topic so maybe I
should actually defer this but its own
thing
we're nog Rafi has been seen as a bad
thing because it you know objectifies
women some people have argued that it
leads to to wreck waves of indirect ways
these are all kind of kind of he to
abuse rape to those sorts of things
those arguments aren't are walking as
what made as they it used to be there
we're living in a culture that is
saturated with pornography it's
available anywhere that you would want
to be and all you have to do is type in
you know a few things on the phone and
you could access to a computer it's no
longer you know the dirty book
underneath the gas station counter I
used to page that you said never work
the gas station that's like Ethel under
the cover ground ever met will come in
and you refer to
there are no kids around we live in a
culture that's so saturated with it and
so many people are using that it's
starting to have interesting effects
that we talked about lowering of libido
a sort of displacement normal sexual
energy even if you're like you don't
think it of the right area and everybody
should be able to do you know whatever
it is that they want so long as we're
not hurting anybody you know Reverb the
kind of thing or it might be a little
bit questionable given its long-term
societal effects I mean it is for me a
toilet Aryan perspective it might be in
some ways liberating a lot of people
access to it and it might be worse to
try to get rid of it altogether because
it reduce a lot of pain for people who
want to actually see it but if it's if
it's leading to if it's affecting
relationships between people and Japeth
even the people who have these sort of
very unlikely words everybody should be
able to do what they want so long as
they're not hurting anybody turns out
that it does hurt them in some ways well
it's what's what's passed on from that
because that's a bigger topic in America
so sexual or even emotional fidelity are
you sleeping with somebody else when
you're supposed to be in a monogamous
committed relationship would that be
okay from utilitarian perspective or
and we might not just think about in
terms of actually having sex with people
or even you know doing lesser things
that some people say it's time to lose
sex by actual count girls and sex race
oh there's kissing and then you know
there's that whole range that sexual
activity right so I don't I don't know
the Clinton line right but you cannot
even flirt with people you can encourage
jealousies you can try to get attention
there's a lot of other things that could
come up you can have emotional Affairs
now how would a utilitarian look at
these things well again I think about
who's being who's made her inclusive
who's not gonna go
I suppose that the utilitarian if it was
a relationship where both partners have
agreed this is an open relationship we
can do what we want and they are
emotionally mature enough where they are
not going to despite having said that
become jealous of the other person and
hurt as a result that a utilitarian
would say that that's absolutely fine
provided that everybody who was involved
in this he is involved in such a way
right everybody would have to be okay
with it in that case in that case
there's really not much point talking
about those where you've already agreed
to be unfaithful so usually we're
talking about people who have some sort
of expectation that their relationship
what they're sharing with each other
sexually
companionship those sorts of things
emotional life are exclusive would it be
okay let's ask a question like this
let's say you have a spouse who has
another spouse and they're not getting
what they need from the other spouse
because the other spouse is screwed up
there's an in person
it's not going to give them what they
want or let's say we go ahead with the
further so that's scenario K scenario B
is you have a spouse who's not getting
what they need what they want from the
the other spouse and it's not because
the other spouse is a mean person it's
because they just can't deliver they're
they're exhausted you know like for
instance I'm you were just watching
Sopranos first season last night and
Carmela says you know I didn't mind the
girlfriends at first because I saw them
as as essentially you know form of
outsourcing I couldn't deliver
everything that that Tony needed and so
great he goes off with the girlfriends
but he's he's not you know getting in my
hair because I had to devote myself to
the house of kids and other things
what's it so the relationship like that
so we got a T we got is the other person
going to get hurt so we had an itch to
have three people involved once we got
the spouse was going to cheat then the
spouse was cheated upon and the mailing
up the other person let's assume that
there's singles so we won't make spouses
so where the the spouse who's cheating
and for the other person you have a
pleasure you know sexual pleasure coming
you know you may also have some pink to
red to worry about am I gonna get caught
all those sorts of things you know to
take that into account that could lower
the amount of total pleasure or all the
utility for the spouse who is being
cheated upon if they find out they are
going to be very hurt presumably even if
they're too suspecting they're going to
be hurt too some ingredients might
happen is if it reaches the tipping
point where this is producing more pain
than pleasure overall any until the
theory would just say forgiveness this
can't possibly be right even if you're
opposing it to option a is as the spouse
cheats option B as the spouse doesn't
she if if option B results in greater
utility even if the spouse is unhappy
they're not getting what they want if it
would produce more unhappiness for them
to actually even taking into account the
sexual pleasure that they're gonna get
then staying you know in the committed
relationship would be the thing to do
now it gets a little bit of different
when we're talking about the the option
B one word was the spouse saying yeah
yet go off and do your thing
I can't give you
I know that it counts as cheating
presumably they're not as unhappy about
it and then the other spouse is a little
less unhappy because they're not worried
about it you did you know another thing
you'd have to take it to accountants
does some people actually get a kick out
of cheating don't they
so that would actually increase the
pleasure for some people for me until
eteri perspective this might be
something that's unattractive to some of
you I know I would have been subtracted
they would say if you can you can cheat
in such a way that it's really turning
you on to do so that would be a good
thing for variant perspective you know
another thing to think about this one to
you know would be from utilitarian
perspective if you can keep the other
person from finding out that produces a
greater balance of pleasures over pains
right because if they find out they're
going to get hurt so if they never find
out you know you most of us would say
it's a bad thing to do whether you get
found out now so latarian you know how
bad is it
it depends on how much pain is produced
this felt so tired of deceiving a
partner or others in relationships if
you can keep them from finding out
something that makes them unhappy that
produces pain for them let's say
somebody's not that attractive right and
they have kind of low self-image
looking to you for affirmation and you
can take care of the right and are you
you are attracted to them but not super
attracted but you you talk to them again
you're the most attractive person in the
world those other people talk about
they're talking about you're great you
know from utilitarian perspective that
would actually be doing a good thing
wouldn't it
tearing somebody down being too critical
would actually be a bad thing that could
that could also be a kind of sucky to
some people deliberately make people
feel worse about themselves in terms of
relationships in terms of romance
section al attractiveness let's think
about a few other things safe sex should
you practice safe sex that's a
no-brainer for me it's military
perspective given the option there's a
lot of ways in which this could happen
and we can even talk about the
abstinence is being the safest of all
but let's say that we're actually
talking about you know trying to prevent
diseases wudu utilitarian be for or
against you know behavior that could
lead to sexual diseases obviously again
it's directives there's no positive
trade off even for somebody like me to
shuffle code who according to reports
went out and got himself needs fairly
deliberately because he wanted to do
some sort of grand experiment which
strikes me it's just totally nuts
all right they paid off in terms of the
pain involved is so much greater than
any sort of pleasure that plant result
so you know that doesn't easy about
breaking up this is something that you
know we have to face in a lot of
relationships most relationships don't
actually work at hope yeah that means
that either this person has to break up
or vice versa or they won't do it at the
same time when should you decide to
break up with a person well and breaking
up with somebody for utilitarian would
not be a purely selfish decision let's
put it this way a utilitarian would
probably not stay it's not you it's me
because if it's them then they have the
opportunity to fix that part of
themselves that's keeping that from
being able to have the relationship and
give the other person the pleasure or
happiness that's involved in the
relationship that obviously they want to
stay in now why don't why do people
break up could because they've been
compatible you know and they sort of
don't fall out there they just don't
really they're not the right people for
each other in some cases it's because
somebody's abusive and then you know
from utilitarian perspective you want to
break up the deaf person even if
breaking up with that person is going to
make that money why because they're
actually making you [ __ ] be happy in
the relationship by being abusive to you
that any pleasure or happiness that they
that they're getting out of it
plus there's probably a lot of other
people in fact if you have kids here in
abusive
you probably need to get out of that and
take the kids away from the abuser right
that's why we have you know shelters and
want a lot of social services from both
ladies yeah it comes to an abusive
relationship a good Benthamite would say
you should probably get out because look
at the balance of pleasures and pains
for all concerned and it's probably a
fairly negative balance probably
affecting a lot of people probably
affect a lot of people are cut up now
when you're breaking up with some here's
another thing many utilitarian say is it
just sort of well now you've said and
break out you have no commitments to
that person want some letter no because
their pleasure pain still matters so you
shouldn't be a jerk would agree if being
honest with that will produce less pain
over the long term than being deceptive
towards them that you should be honest
if you can say you know what it is that
you you don't like about that person
without calling them a bunch of names
that make them feel bad without tearing
them down and you should do that that
means of latarian perspective if you're
being broken up with I guess you can
tilt it area going off a lot but please
support you with it so you see that
until the terrorism can can apply to all
different sorts of
issues in romance and shoe ality desire
human attraction relationships and it
doesn't always take the perspective that
whatever gives you the most pleasure so
long against nobody's getting physically
hurt and/or rules are being broken or
anything like that but it's always okay
there you know a utility 300 look at
things in the long term and in the wide
range they would look at how this
affects people besides just you and
besides just the person that you're
involved with whether it affects other
people
yes as a result that's important to take
into account so that's probably enough
about these issues I'm going to shoot
some other videos having to do with
other important aspects of our life and
utilitarianism as well